so last week I interviewed Sean Flynn on
the Singapore healthcare system and I
thought that for today's classic
interview we'd go back to an interview
with former Cigna executive wendell
potter who's been on the program a
number of times he's talked about his
great book deadly spin which by the way
several years old now if you haven't
read it I highly recommend you check it
out and we interviewed wendell potter
specifically about the united kingdom's
national healthcare system and we went
through many of the common talking
points from the right who like to talk
about just how absolutely terrible the
british health care system is and in
particular context with the singapore
health care system we're gonna go back
to this interview from march of 2015 to
end with wendell potter to review how a
totally nationalized health care system
can work and again the broader context
for me is thinking about how might we be
able to improve the American health care
system whether you like or dislike the
Singaporean health care system whether
you think that the British health care
system has problems what's abundantly
clear from any measure of the data is
that the system we have here is an
absolute and total disaster so let's go
back to my interview from March of 2015
with former health insurance executive
wendell potter i'm joined today by
wendell potter who is former VP of
corporate communications at Cigna also
author of the book deadly spin and most
recently Obamacare what's in it for me
what everyone needs to know about the
Affordable Care Act Wendell it's great
to have you back of course and you
recently wrote a very interesting
article talking about the United
Kingdom's national health care program
that they have it's a topic of much
controversy it's often used by those in
the US who are against any kind of
government involvement in health care to
point to other countries that have
government health care programs and to
talk about how poor they are the long
wait times the very high cost the
spending per person the high tax rates
that people in those countries have as a
result of these government programs you
looked specifically at the UK and maybe
not surprisingly to some of our audience
a lot of those
talking points seem to not be true oh
it's exactly you're exactly right David
and I even mentioned in that post that
during my career in the insurance
industry I used to spend considerable
time trying to mislead people about the
National Health Service in the UK and
the Canadian health system and other
systems that were single-payer or that
were very heavily regulated by the
government which is just which is every
other healthcare system in the developed
world
so let's go through what we do know and
and kind of these objections that become
cart part part of this mantra that is
against these types of programs with
regard to what we hear about
accessibility of care long wait times
etc what's the truth about the UK NHS
system well the truth is that on almost
every measure of outcomes and and and
patient satisfaction UK is way ahead of
the United States and what I wrote about
in that piece was first-person accounts
of people who are either expats from the
UK and have lived in the US or people
who have dual citizenship and have used
both both systems and without without
any hesitation they all said that they
would much rather get their care in the
UK some people said that even though
they were living in the u.s. they fly
back to the UK to get care from for a
lot of reasons one is the cost it's much
less expensive in the UK and second it's
far less complicated we have what I
guess probably the most complicated
healthcare systems on the planet and
when we look at the the outcomes I think
that this is a really interesting
element because if we put aside for a
second long waits in in many cases those
are kind of anecdotal stories that we
hear about long waits so if we put that
aside for a second particularly when it
appears not to be true broadly either
when we look at outcomes we often hear
touted that in the u.s. in spite of the
fact that we have a kind of employer
connected and or private insurance
system as the predominant one that the
the outcomes are actually better here
are there some specific statistics
or conditions that you can talk to us
about that illustrate why that is not
true
well you're right the the arguments
against the National Health Service that
have been put out by opponents here in
the u.s. are anecdotal they are
anecdotes and and it they are there
they're done specifically to obscure the
reality all the better outcomes the
Commonwealth Fund every every year does
an analysis of the health care systems
around the globe and in the developed
world and they they rate them as do on
various measures on outcomes on
accessibility on cost among other things
and last year the UK system came out
well ahead of every other system and
certainly well ahead of the UK system
they looked at 11 countries the UK was
first and the US was 11th now hopefully
the US will start to climb up because we
passed the Affordable Care Act and that
survey or that work that was done by the
Commonwealth Fund was based on the
experience in 2013 and in the next year
2014 last year is when a lot of the
provisions the Affordable Care Act
kicked in but to answer your question a
lot of the outcomes in the UK are much
superior to ours one of the things that
it's really important is Excel access to
primary care which is much more readily
available in the UK and one of the
reasons why they have more they have
better infirmity ality Statistics and
longevity statistics let's talk a little
bit now if we concede temporarily even
though as we know there's no reason to
do this but if we were to concede that
the let me let me frame it a different
way let's focus just on this issue of
taxes right so if we can say okay we can
have a system that works well that is
either private insurance or
government-funded we can have a system
that that is that works well that is a
government system where you can have
either a social safety net or straight
up single-payer health care but the
problem is that it's very expensive
taxpayers if we analyze that data I
looked specifically at Australia as well
as at the UK it does not actually appear
that there is a significantly higher tax
burden for individuals based on having
that national health care program no
you're exactly right because of the
efficiencies that you can get in a
system that is operated largely by the
government or at least financed by the
government in which you can remove a lot
of a hidden costs that we have in this
system a lot of these Menace rate
expenses that then make our health care
system the most expensive in the world
we spend it's been estimated at about a
thirty percent of what we spent on
health care is in many cases wasted or
at least characterized as administrative
expenses that don't have anything to do
with the delivery of care so you say
that money right off the bat and one of
the things we that it's difficult for
advocates of reform to communicate
effectively to Americans is that we pay
a lot in a hidden tax for the care that
we that we get for the insurance that we
get we tend to think that if we get our
air comes through the workplace that
that's our employer taking care of that
but actually it's our money so if you
what we need to do is consider all that
we spend on health care and including
what we spend on premiums and we can see
that it's far enough
far and away much more than any other
country spends I want to go back to
something you wrote about in deadly spin
and I often reference this but over the
years since I've read this passage now a
few years ago I forget that some of the
details and I think it would be very
interesting to review you wrote in the
book that the u.s. at one point was
actually early in the 20th century going
in the direction of single-payer and if
I recall correctly because it was
similar to what our enemy Germany seemed
to be doing there was a successful
campaign mounted to oppose going in the
direction of single-payer merely because
it was similar to what our enemy was
doing am I remembering that more or less
correctly you really are in fact we have
been trying to reform a health care
system for more than a hundred years it
goes back
to the administration of Teddy Roosevelt
who is trying to do exactly what you
described but there was a fear mongering
Kane of a campaign that developed even
back then to try to scare people away
from from the German health care system
Germany was one of the first developed
countries I think it was the first in
Europe to go down the path of providing
health care more broadly for its
citizens and when we look going forward
you'd know firsthand about the
propaganda campaigns that have been used
here in the u.s. from the port
for-profit insurers to put down the
programs like that that originated in
Germany in the UK in Australia etc what
might get the the dialogue to change
successfully in terms of having serious
conversations around national health
care I mean we know that when you fairly
ask individuals do you believe the
government has some responsibility to
provide at least basic care for
everybody regardless of ability to pay
that's actually very popular but when it
gets wrapped in around corporate talking
points is where it seems to fall apart
it's exactly right
corporations that offer or sell health
insurance are very very profitable and
they have a lot of money to invest in PR
campaigns to mislead people so we've got
to realize that's why I wrote deadly
spin to explain to people how that works
we've got to come up with strategies
that can overcome that and I think it's
possible we just have to know to start
with while we're up against all right
we've been speaking with former VP of
corporate communications at Cigna
Wendell Potter one of the books deadly
spin the most recent book Obamacare
what's in it for me what everyone needs
to know about the Affordable Care Act
thanks as always Wendell thank you David